Y el color que tanto le gustaba usar era quizá lo único
que la identificaba de verdad,
lo único que podía decidir,
porque al igual que la mayoría de las mujeres de su generación en India
nunca había tenido la oportunidad de existir
fuera de los cánones impuestos por la costumbre y la tradición.
Se había casado a los 17,
y luego de 65 años de matrimonio, cuando un día mi abuelo murió inesperadamente,
esa pérdida le resultó insoportable.
Pero ese día perdería algo más;
su única alegría:
usar ropa de colores.
Según la tradición india,
cuando una mujer queda viuda,
el único color que puede usar es el blanco
desde el momento en que fallece su esposo.
Nadie la obligó a vestir de blanco.
Sin embargo, todas las mujeres que conocía y que habían sobrevivido a sus maridos,
incluyendo a su propia madre,
lo habían hecho.
Esta opresión estaba tan internalizada,
tan arraigada,
que hasta ella misma se negó a elegir.
Falleció este año,
y hasta el día de su muerte
siguió usando exclusivamente el color blanco.
Conservo una foto suya de años anteriores, más felices.
Allí no se ven los colores que usa.
Es una foto en blanco y negro.
Pero, a juzgar por su sonrisa,
se deduce que su ropa es de colores.
Esta es otra cosa que la moda puede hacer.
Tiene el poder de llenarnos de alegría.
la alegría de poder elegir libremente y por nosotros mismos cómo vestirnos,
cómo queremos vivir.
Es una libertad por la que vale la pena luchar.
Y en esa lucha por la libertad, la protesta adopta diversas formas.
Las viudas como mi abuela de la India viven, junto a otras miles,
en una ciudad llamada Vrindavan.
Desde hace siglos, las viudas conforman allí un verdadero mar blanco.
Sin embargo, recién en el año 2013,
las viudas de Vrindavan han empezado a celebrar el "Holi",
el festival de color de la India,
donde les estaba prohibido participar.
En este único día de marzo,
las mujeres se arrojan polvos de colores,
que es la tradición del festival.
Con cada puñado de polvo que arrojan al aire,
sus saris blancos empiezan lentamente a cubrirse de colores.
Y no se detienen hasta estar completamente cubiertas
con las tonalidades de un arco iris que les está prohibido.
El color desaparece al día siguiente,
pero, al menos por una vez,
son parte de una bella disrupción.
Esta disrupción,
y cualquier otra disonancia,
puede ser la primera chispa en la batalla contra la opresión.
Y la moda
puede representar un quiebre en la estética visual
en nosotros, literalmente.
Los grandes revolucionarios de la moda son los diseñadores
que siempre han hecho demostraciones de verdadera rebeldía:
Jean Paul Gaultier nos enseñó que las mujeres pueden ser reyes.
Thom Browne nos enseñó que los hombres pueden usar tacones.
Y Alexander McQueen, en la presentación de su colección de primavera en 1999,
instaló dos enormes brazos robotizados en medio de la pasarela,
y mientras la modelo Shalom Harlow giraba entre ellos,
estos dos robots, tímidamente al principio y luego con furia
empezaron a rociarla con pintura de color.
De este modo, McQueen nos enseñó
-—antes de quitarse la vida—
que nuestro cuerpo es un lienzo
que podemos pintar del modo que nos plazca.
A quien le encantaba este mundo de la moda
era a Karar Nushi.
Era un estudiante y actor iraquí.
Le fascinaba la ropa llamativa, ecléctica.
Pero empezó a recibir amenazas de muerte por la forma en que se vestía.
No se inmutó.
Siguió siendo fabuloso,
hasta que en julio de 2017
fue encontrado muerto en una concurrida calle de Bagdad.
Lo habían secuestrado.
Lo habían torturado.
Un testigo dijo que el cuerpo presentaba múltiples heridas.
Heridas de arma blanca.
A 3200 km de Peshawar,
Alisha, activista transexual pakistaní,
recibió múltiples disparos en mayo de 2016.
Fue trasladada al hospital
pero como vestía ropa de mujer
se le negó el acceso al pabellón masculino y también al femenino.
La ropa que decidimos usar
puede significar, literalmente, la diferencia entre la vida y la muerte.
Y a veces, ni siquiera podemos decidir sobre nuestra muerte.
Alisha murió ese día
y fue sepultada como un hombre.
¿En qué mundo vivimos?
Pues bien, uno en el que sentir temor es natural;
temor a esta vigilancia,
a esta violencia contra el cuerpo y la manera en que nos vestimos.
Sin embargo, el gran temor es que si nos rendimos,
si no nos diferenciamos
y empezamos a desaparecer uno atrás de otro,
más normal parecerá esta falsa aceptación,
menos asfixiante nos resultará esta opresión.
Por los niños que estamos criando,
la injusticia de hoy puede ser lo común de mañana.
Se acostumbrarán,
y ellos también pueden llegar a creer que lo distinto es sucio,
digno de ser odiado,
suprimido,
como luces que se apagan, una a una,
hasta que la oscuridad se transforma en un modo de vida.
Pero si hoy yo,
mañana Uds.
y quizá muchos otros algún día
defendemos el derecho de vestirnos como deseamos,
en un mundo que ha sido violentamente privado de color,
y seremos ese rayo de color que abre una luz en el camino,
como las viudas de Vrindavan.
¿Cómo es posible entonces que siendo tantos nosotros
la mira de un armapueda apuntar a Karar,
a Malala,
a Alisha?
¿Pueden matarnos a todos?
Es hora de ponerse de pie,
de salir del montón.
En un mundo donde la uniformidad brinda seguridad,
con algo tan simple como la ropa
podemos hacer que los ojos ajenos se posen en nosotros
para decir que en este mundo hay diferencias y que siempre las habrá.
Acostumbrémonos a eso.
Y esto se puede decir sin pronunciar una sola palabra.
La moda puede ser un lenguaje de disenso.
Nos puede dar valor.
La moda es, literalmente, la oportunidad de ponernos el traje de la valentía.
Usémoslo.
Usémoslo como armadura.
Usémoslo porque es importante.
Y usémoslo porque Uds. son importantes.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)